well you should just turn it on in case
we do talk to you
you're listening to the dollop
bilingual american history all things
comedy network we're on the all things
comedy network where each week i
where of watches
man who likes sandwiches
lover of cheese dave anthony who reads
this picture you've painted of yourself
there from american history wow
to a guy i know named gareth reynolds
who has no idea what the topic is going
to be about hey congrats on that cheese
that's quite a credit
in wisconsin you could have your own
theater there's
you guys have so much cheese that you
put wet cheese in a bag and pretend like
it's good i'm sorry if you're
trying to hurl curd accusations this way
save it for a better battle it's a save
it for a battle you can win reality it's
a cheese reality what's your problem you
don't like uh it's [ __ ] disgusting
you don't like a watery cheese
not in the bag have you ever you've
never played pool cheese is your whole
piece of
in the pool and then you eat it like
pac-man is your whole country like a
carnival like why the [ __ ] like walking
around the state why would you watch it
is your whole state of country get your
head out of your ass you don't know what
a state is you don't know what a country
is and you sure as [ __ ] don't know
what's good about cheese
it was meant to be in water it was
discovered in water
and called it quote his jam pack champ
i'm the [ __ ] hippo guy dave okay my
name's gary my name's gary wait is it
for fun and this is not gonna become the
tickling podcast okay this is like adam
and a five-part confession
now hit him with a puppy
you both present sick arguments no sleep
deal hippo
action partner
hi gabby
um there you go so you did that that was
really
aggressive
well i mean you picked a you picked a
wound that you should not uh that
doesn't need picking
cheese
cheese curds as long as we understand
it's a wound
yeah
huh
you just described cheese curds as a
wound no i didn't i described you no
it's it's a
we're brought to you in part
by
keeps
look uh dudes lose their hair some guys
are fine with it a lot of guys are not
fine with it it's a bummer you start
your hair you always had it now it's
going away sure two out of three men are
gonna get some form of hair loss by the
time 35 you for instance more than
50 million men in the us suffer from
male pattern baldness
sure thank you
and now there's only at this point
there's only two fda approved
medications that can prevent hair loss
and guess what keeps offers
both
nice keep it man
uh look keeps offers a simple
stress-free way to keep your hair
i would like to keep my hair would you
like to keep your hair i keep your hair
in a bag in my desk convenient virtual
doctor consultations medications come
straight to your door delivered every
three months like it's super easy secret
it's easy sure you get to keep your hair
people want their hair sure
uh it's low cost you can treatment start
at just 10 bucks a month they got
generic versions discreet packaging i
guess it comes in like a
maybe it looks like golf balls
titleists
uh and it has more than five star
reviews
than any other competitor so yeah and
look with male pattern balance if you're
if you're trying to keep your hair it's
prevention that you want to
that's really you want to get it before
it gets too bad right
yeah and treatments can take up to four
to six months so you know jump on it now
if it's worrying you and i'm all for you
know whatever makes you feel better
that's my call yeah that's right yeah
you know you've always been very
yes that's always been how you've been
very open
you always yeah go ahead
three two if you're ready to take action
and prevent hair loss go to k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash dog to get uh to receive
your first month of treatment for free
that's k-e-e-p-s dot com slash dog to
get your first month free k-e-e-p-s dot
com slash a dolla
we're also brought to you in part by a
squarespace
our baby looks great our baby we've been
working with squarespace for years uh
it's a domain website online store
marketing tool analytic company they do
everything they're it's from websites to
online stores
squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business we here at the dollop
we're all in on squarespace
we got our dolloppodcast.com or you can
look at our tour information we got
uh garris web page comedy webpage mine
uh we got our sources page all
squarespace y because uh squarespace is
very easy to use like you say you can do
everything
with one shot there and it makes it so
much easier and then it looks nice the
templates yeah clean smooth they look
really good you're in the game you're in
the game finally in the game and you can
go in and uh
you know mess around with the template
see how it looks see if it works for you
and then if you like it you sign up you
jump on board that's what i did i went
and played around with it i was like oh
this is exactly what i want
super easy 24 7 award-winning support
so look man i'm telling you get on board
with squarespace check out
squarespace.com dollar free trial and
when you're ready to launch use offer
code dollop to save 10 off your first
purchase
of a website or domain
we're also brought to you
in part by a squarespace we just did
squarespace sorry we're also brought to
you in part by stamps.com yes much
better
um i've been using stamps.com for a
while now it makes things super easy why
because
i can just i have a little scale now
that they sent me you just plug it into
your computer
you put your
what box on it whatever you want up
comes the postage price you print it up
you slap that baby on the package put it
outside
postman comes and gets it or post lady
or post binary yes whatever you want to
do yes post non-binary yes uh so uh
if you don't want to go to the post
office some people like i don't want to
make that trip i don't want to deal with
the post office
uh it's sad because silvia's there and
she's very nice but i'm not seeing her
anymore where are the people she's very
confused i don't understand anymore uh
she used to be hustle and bustle it's
not anymore it's all
stamps.com
uh you can send letters ship packages
you pay less you pay a lot less they got
discounted rates from you sps and ups
and tons of tons of businesses use
stamps.com everyone's everyone's doing
this you get up to forty percent
discounts
on the post office and it's a 66 off ups
shipping rates ups of course the good
company because they're
unionized
uh so stamps.com is a no-brainer saving
you time and money it's no wonder nearly
one million small businesses use them
including
gareth reynolds that's right it is a
business
so stop wasting time go to the post
office and go to stamps.com instead
there's no risk and with our promo code
you get a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus free postage and a
digital scale no long term uh
commitments or contracts just go to
stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the home page and type in
dollop at stamps.com promo code
dobstamps.com never go to the post
office again
yeah
and last but not least we are brought to
you by ultimate
ears
now
i am i've been a big airpod guy for a
while yes i enjoy the the bluetooth
no cord situation i also enjoy it you do
but it took you a lot longer to get on
board well i've just recently really
enjoyed it yeah so
uh
i'm always looking for a better one
and then these things came uh they sent
us each pair because they're like do you
want to work with us and we said well
why don't you send us a thing and we'll
we'll let you know yeah i don't think
there was any tension in any way that
you're kind of making and send it right
okay so
we get we get the ultimate ears the fits
and i i put them in my ears and i'm like
oh these things don't feel great
what is this and then i look at the
directions you bring up an app
and you connect it to your ear your
little earpiece
and then it it gets hot in your ear yes
and you're like oh my time is here what
i'm dying what is happening and then you
realize it's
it's it's crazy slightly molding
nobody's plastic to your ears that this
exhibit this technique that we were
there i had no idea technologically i
was like well we're not there and then
in your ear this thing is heating up
molding itself and you're going wait so
my phone is heating my headphones
and then they fit so good yes then it's
that it's perfect then you have ear
gloves yeah it's amazing at that point
uh it's a whole new experience it is i
mean you know people say it's kind of oh
it's a new
uh experience in this thing this really
is this really is a brand new experience
it's a whole new level of your of
earbuds or earpods or whatever you want
to call them um earbuds i think they
would be called sure so i i cannot
recommend enough they sound amazing
because they fit so good you listen to
whatever you want music you got your
phone calls
going on there anything working out
whatever things music
people know that you can listen to those
things podcasts again we don't need the
list so
uh so like i said they're the most
comfortable earbuds premium sound
super comfortable
uh
it takes like 60 seconds for them for
them to you want it to go longer though
you do you're like don't end
uh eight hours of uh playback on a
charge up to 20 hours with the charging
case so you know that's it's just
wonderful like i can't say how wonderful
enough it is listen to you
so if you uh try fits you don't love
them as much as gareth and i do ultimate
ears offers a 30-day money-back
guarantee plus you'll get free shipping
free returns and a one-year warranty so
look for a limited time get 15 off your
pair of ultimate ears fits true wireless
earbuds at ue.com
fits use promo code dollop at checkout
that's 15 off with promo code dollop at
ue.com
fits
join us and also join us on some live
shows we'll be doing uh that you can go
to
dolloppodcast.com for ticket information
all these shows i'm about to say the
september 14th will be wise guys in las
vegas the 16th wise guy salt lake city
high plains comedy festival saturday
september 18th in denver at the
paramount theater wednesday september
22nd we're at stand up live in phoenix
friday november 5th palace of the fine
arts san francisco november 6 crest
theater sacramento and december 10th we
will be at the observatory in north park
in san diego and for those of you who
haven't heard our australia tour is
postponed what uh oh boy let's talk
after babe nothing to worry about
everything's fine i keep dave in a room
of pillows where no bad news permeates
uh i will also be doing some stand-up
comedy uh september 10th and september
11th i will be at the stress factory in
new jersey uh like i said we'll be there
for that caroline's oh we just announced
this i'll be at caroline's headlining in
new york city that's where they make the
good salsa that's september 24th
september 25th caroline's two shows uh a
night at 7 and 9 30. you can go to my
website garethreynos.com for information
on all this then i'll also be at the
stress factory in bridgeport connecticut
october 1st and october 2nd join me
check you out yeah
we got a lot going on kid
hey this kids when will you get coveted
i have i have a bunch of it
tons of it
it's fine
um aaron i'm gonna send you
a couple of photos ooh
how do i get to see me on that
no no no no no no no no no no okay now
we got the i got that going we got the
whole i got a whole operation here i got
yeah computer i got an ipad i got a
couple i feel like you're looking for
tornadoes
um
oh i'm always looking for two you just
need like one of those vests with lots
of pockets um they call me looking for
tiny tornadoes dave yeah that's right or
toenail
tornado i'm not into it please stop
laughing
please stop talking
okay it was gonna be a weird podcast i
think it'll be great i've got a good
feeling but understandable yeah
i like how people have been like
they sound so much happier when they're
in the studio as opposed to on zoom
yeah yeah
yeah better it's a better experience it
turns out when you're trying to do
comedy improv together it helps to be in
the same timing the no lag in time helps
yeah it really does when you're you're
pausing to see if the other guy's saying
something i'm gonna get you something to
place your ipad on this is i got my
mother a thing that we call flippy
which is a little thing which little
pillow she puts her ipad on she loves it
i got one for my aunt too loves it i'm
gonna get you a flippy because you're
over here balancing it on water am i
going to bring a pillow into the studio
though is that what we're asking no
you're going to bring flippy into the
studio yep so but it's a pillow it's a
flippy
stop i'm not going to do it you just
said it was a pillow i described the
body type of flippy to you it's pillowy
it doesn't mean flippy's a pillow it
does
okay you know what [ __ ] you you're not
getting it
i tried he's not getting a flippy i was
going to get him a flippy done i see it
yeah it's a pillow
this
let's just start please i'm not gonna
it's a pillow
i'm about to do it it's shaped it's
shaped like a flipping like it holds
something but it's a pillow yes it's
shaped like a flippy right it's an ipod
pillow stop it
it's an ipad pillow first of all
[Laughter]
owned you don't have a leg to stand on
september 4th 1312. i love when
everything gets so hot and spicy like
this before we start yep yeah people
like we sound so much happier
[Laughter]
1958 year of our lord jesus christ jesus
christo
sure
jeffrey edward
fowle was born in a winter park to
parents edward and virginia okay
now edward was in the air force okay at
an air force base there in florida
and then he was transferred to a base
outside dayton ohio when jeffrey was
young okay
so that's where jeffy grew up in ohio
uh they built a house in nearby beaver
creek sure which i'm sure in which all
of the beavers have been killed i think
there's a beaver creek in every midwest
there has to be state yeah beaver dammer
creek yep yeah
or beaverton
sure yeah right yeah right something
where they're like this is where the
beavers there were a lot of beavers here
we killed them all now we have coats we
got a bunch of beaver over here so we
named this whole town beavertown and
nobody's done anything like this except
for the other seven states that uh
surround us basically where can i see
the beavers now well unfortunately
you're not gonna be able to see much of
that what you're gonna do is you're
gonna it's a regular town no it used to
be riddled with beavers but uh not
anymore because uh well many reasons but
mainly uh we were looking to open it
about like 30 houses that look identical
so we opened like 30 houses that i have
like minor tweaks to them for the most
part but uh yeah so there's no beavers
but um some people say at night if you
listen closely you can hear their
screams
why are they screaming uh because they
were murder day callously yes yeah two
in order to take over the area uh-huh
yeah so uh and you still kept the name
though well of course we did what are we
gonna do change what are we gonna call
it houseville it sounds like everywhere
else no but some people say if you close
your eyes you will see an apparition of
a beaver and he will haunt you
perpetually
i don't want to live here yeah no a lot
of people uh
it's because we don't have a gym
so uh
so they regularly the family regularly
went to uh saint mark's episcopal church
that was their church
but then edward started having like a
wandering religious eye he's checking
out other religions oh okay i thought
this was going to be like he was
thinking of sleeping with sleeping
around but no he's no no he's sleeping
with other churches so yeah right no
he's the bad he's the deity bachelor
that's right i'm open
hey what's going on over there with bat
baptism hey
what's up i had a great time with you
the other night i'm just hopeful that um
you would love to be a part of this
because it's really good i wouldn't i
know that you and lutherans have been
talking and yeah i've been chatting but
i don't have the same kind of hotness i
agree that i have for you i agree with
you i want to take you upstairs and just
rip everything off oh i'm wetter than a
bull you'd put a baby yeah let's then
i'm going to get super baptist right now
yeah great i mean that's great [ __ ]
holding snakes and [ __ ] that's out
sorry that's uh excuse me i think you're
talking about us
what's that i think you're talking about
us that is not they do not do that
that's what we do
we're pentecostal hey what's up let's
get crazy i get so confused when it gets
to the snakes well i'm the snake one got
a snake thing i'm the snake one
right so what are we doing are we
[ __ ] well sure we will after the
venom courses through us and that's how
we know that our connection to the lord
is strong you don't need to put your
hand up you're in charge of the show i
have the venom
well yeah i think technically i think
from a biblical perspective so here's
what's happening go ahead you're talking
about your trouser snake i'm talking
about actual venomous snakes that we'll
put onto our arms and necks and then
when they bite us we'll be okay because
if there's one thing that this
particular religion gets rid of it's
poison from bodies
so i just wanted to [ __ ] until i had an
orgasm that was my sort of totally in
the cards for us okay after the snakes
have her their way we cut the snake
absolutely not
you know there's another religion over
here i'm gonna go check out my lutherans
over here hey
we're pretty similar but sort of crazy
so uh he gets into this church called
the worldwide church of god there we go
and the reason it was worldwide is
because
he the
guy who started it use tv and radio to
get to people all over the world okay
commercials and radio stations sure
so the religion was based on the old
testament and british israelism which
said that whites of britain were
descended from king david okay sure i
mean pretty specific of course and why
would it not be of course again i mean
there we are it's just
hey we're we're uh british whites we uh
we gotta have something really [ __ ]
awesome i like the idea that if there is
god
she put us down here and basically made
our skin star trek uniforms and so we're
a tiered
world of people who are like whites are
the captains and we're in charge we're
the whites we're the picards
we had a board meeting our school board
meeting yesterday and three dudes called
up to discuss crt
critical race theory oh jesus christ
none of whom are parents in the district
oh my god just random white bros
hey so i just don't want my kids to live
near any other schools that are teaching
it one guy's from orange county he's
like i might move there orange county
yeah can you believe that yeah
uh so i will i'm going to have a
rebuttal in the next meeting and it's
going to be
tremendous
so uh edward dives into his his new
church okay um
they're not the same rules as a a lot of
other religions and no christmas so he
bans the family from
from enjoying always goes over well with
children instead of a lie and even if he
wasn't he's dead
so instead he they were just going to
celebrate new testament celebration and
that's fun
yeah those are the best that's fine
so then in late 1967
he takes the kids out of school one day
and drives to the poconos
i like this religion where they
celebrated the feast of the tabernacles
sure yep which we all know yeah it's a
big one i think jewish people celebrate
that but i'm not really well that's
what's great about this religion it's
able to it's a bit of a potpourri it's
like a charcuterie plate of god what
what's this shirt
it's when you eat different pieces of
shark with cheese which reminds me the
best kind of cheese hey it's me from
earlier it's not good okay i'll go away
uh this this trip did not go over uh
too well one son jamie ran through a
window and cut his eyelids open
i read that four times he ran through a
window and i read this well blinking
ain't in the boys cards anymore
that's fine
how do you without like because it
doesn't it sounds like he didn't cut the
eyes he just cut the eyelids open
i you're getting for there's a lot of uh
going to be some
dehydration
because you need moisture in there so if
you have
problems with your lids
i don't think it's it's not great it's
one of those things we take advantage
like we just take for granted all the
time where it's like
where our eyelids are causing like there
you go that'll keep the eye going and
we're like god something in my eye yeah
but all day it's like perfect perfect
you lose those you know it's not great
yeah it's [ __ ] yeah
so uh got what's called clockwork
orangitis or rockeitis or arachiitis
so uh another daughter lynn while they
were in the poconos came down with
pneumonia so not a great trip maybe
maybe this religion
has given us some red flags i believe
that a good religion challenges you okay
so when when that was over virginia is
just done with edward's new [ __ ]
religion and she goes back to saint
mark's okay
so
well with the kids with two kids okay so
the leader of the worldwide keep the
eyelids here
so
the leader of the world by church now
tells his flock that they could either
serve god or the government oh my gosh
now edward edward's in the air force
so
he leaves the air force wow and he'd
been a member for 13 years any pension
he built up was gone
but then he goes back to work on the
base as a private consultant so he's
doing the same [ __ ] job without the
benefits god
god hates made him get rid of the
benefit that's god hates benefits
yeah people don't realize that so weird
how god's like god hates benefit
healthcare should be attached to your
job
lord we understand it is confusing and
seems like you're adding far too many
layers but we shall uh disperse your
language sir pensions are for satanists
okay certainly strange people love us
security nets but understandable
your eye care plan is
[ __ ]
you said i care plan that's right okay
i guess a lot of us weren't didn't know
we had an eye care plan so
and you no longer have delta dental oh
come on our teeth are terrible well
what's
is there still a copay
there's no copay because you don't have
it it's gone it's a benefit christ no
likey hey that's just james at a tree
get him
i'm your boss
uh so the family
family's split now the like i said two
kids are an eyelid two kids are going
with virginia to saint mark's
two other kids are going with dad to the
worldwide church well which jeffrey is
one of those jeffrey jeffries good go go
with this guy i like him but then but
then when he turns 12 he's like i'm done
i'm i'm done jeffrey's done with
churches okay come out okay so he stops
going to church completely
but he's still religious and in high
school
uh jeffrey's in the photo
and chess clubs and also the bible club
it's amazing like but but it's like it's
also like it just shows you how wrong is
debt like his dad was just making
terrible decisions because he's like
look dad i love god and religion you're
just [ __ ] it all
you're up you're going with the crazy
[ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah yeah what about god but
without the fun [ __ ] like christmas i
mean really yeah and also by the way
what's great is even if you don't go to
church you can really celebrate
christmas yeah you can knock that [ __ ]
out of the park otherwise there's a war
on it
wow
so i was pulling out the troops from the
war on christmas you're here i did not
yeah
so a neighbor said uh that jeffrey was
nerdy
quiet but friendly okay
now the cold war is really happening now
and jeffrey
becomes very fascinated with communist
countries oh here we go here we go and
he starts obsessively reading about the
soviet union okay as all kids do yes of
course very very yeah it's awesome
after high school he goes to the
agricultural institute of ohio and while
he was there he took russian classes
okay so he's learning how to speak
russian
and then one night in college he has a
dream oh boy
jeffrey it is i you're his best friend
hey it's a god what's up
with russian
oh lord this russian do you not know
your picture of the american accent it's
so westernized for you to imagine that
god for your accent what the ego you
have a what ego you have
do you know there's a god junior he's a
bear
eagle
we do we do have an eagle where eagle
this is an eagle country no no not eagle
eagle eagle ego
eagle no you go like a oh christ what
noise eagle make yeah really great
[Music]
[Laughter]
so
he has his dream when he's in college
and in the dream he's looking down on
this revival that's happening in this
valley sure and he's not liking them and
he's saying bad things about him and
then behind him
he hears quote
don't make fun of them they are sincere
in what they do
obviously that's god who else would be
behind you talking
it's only one for sure thing
yeah so
after god says that
a mist comes
and jeffrey's like well i'm being
cleansed
okay because that's all that's a dream
mist
yeah it's a dream i think he's
ejaculating i've had this before it's a
no no no no why does it have to be dirty
it's just a guy having an amazing
religion okay somebody's having a
mistake no i don't it's just a guy
that's just normally when i wake up and
i go oh no well he did wake up and his
pillow was soaked with tears yes oh
tears okay nevermind
uh so now jeffrey's like well clearly
god has a plan for me sure what else
would you take away from that uh maybe
that's the kid without the eyelids he's
been walking around and it's like
could be that yeah
okay that's very specific right i get it
so now
this had a big impact on me graduates
with a degree in agriculture in 1983
and
he gives away everything he owns okay
he's got some stuff he keeps in his car
but he gives away everything and then he
packs what he can into his 88 rambler i
think he just needed to like room for
the car
but he was like i'm being magnanimous
so
he's got an 88 rambler ambassador
i don't even know what that is you know
what it is i know the exact it's a
gremlin yeah i know but
was it was it always a rambler
ambassador oh i don't have any idea what
kind of car this is i'm just picturing a
gremlin
it has to be like
i feel like every car from them was
basically a gremlin aaron's gonna find a
picture of it but i i yeah so i wonder
if there's different rambler types or
whatever right
so
he packs what he has left okay and he
drives across the country to death
valley
great great yeah this is just what you
do for sure that's where you go
uh
so if people don't know what death
valley is it's the hottest [ __ ] just
a cool chill place to live and raise a
family and not worry about that that's
right it's uh you're away from
everything you want to fry an egg in
your hand well here's your spot i gave
you a great example of how hot death
valley is i went there when i was like
23 or something and i was driving around
with my hands on the steering wheel and
i didn't realize but my knuckles were
cooking
through the windshield and then they
were like they were like all hardened
and custom tri-tip
hell my hand
so
he gets the death valley he drives to a
canyon
smart by the way these are where that's
where you want to be in death valley oh
get get down can't go better yeah
he parks his car okay
and then he writes a note
and he puts it under the windshield
wiper and the note says whoever finds
his car can keep it
and he takes the title out of the glove
box and puts another bunch of wiper too
jesus and then he walks off
into the
canyon death valley sure okay
it's all also did i tell
it's called death valley for a reason
it's because you die there yeah it's so
hot it's barren that you'll die there
that's right right
so what he's thinking of
was christ's fast for 40 days you know
and that makes sense a lot of people
said that was basically the ambassador
of fasting so are you talking about the
rambler ambassador the rambler
ambassador absolutely
so has anyone seen the ambassador no but
that's just how he is
so
he doesn't eat for four days
okay all he has with him is a bed roll i
assume a bed roll a bed roll i assume
you had water but what's a bed roll like
a little thing a little mat i mean i
would describe it as like a yoga mat
okay right it's almost like that sort of
version of things
um
he must have had water or
he was staying near plate because there
are places where there are there is
water like where the pupfish are and
sure but not a lot of water right
but somebody he walks on for four
[ __ ] days he he was running into
other people who were also on like
spiritual walks like it's uh we're dying
we're also dying i can't find my car
yeah yeah yeah it's kind of a spiritual
walk but more i just want to get to my
honda four of my friends died on my wall
so
he walks home for four days without
eating and then on the fifth day just
like christ
jeffrey goes back to his car yeah just
like jesus did yes
and there the note has been removed
it was hard the rangers found the car
and like hey man you can't just [ __ ]
leave a car out here and
and just say people can have it and
they've taken the they'd taken the uh
title and put it back in the club
crazy i feel like that would not be done
now i know i feel like people be like no
they would tow it in the [ __ ] yeah
how do we make money
so obviously this is an amazing
spiritual adventure and he he stays in
california for a little while after that
working odd jobs and then heads back to
ohio and moves in with his parents who
are somehow still married right
and
jeffrey then decides to take the
officer's exam for the air force
like his dad was a pilot but he has bad
eyesight and he can't do it and they're
like what about working at other
part navigation or whatever and so he
goes okay and he goes to texas to
take the officer's training program okay
immediately funks out okay good
good in 1988 he takes a job with the
street department in moraine ohio okay
clearing snow in the winter and fixing
you know cracks and whatever in the
summer okay
it's a dream job sure what you do with
an agricultural degree yeah yeah you go
to the streets you street you start yeah
you street clown yep yep right yeah and
then put
tara we've got a good harlot this good
harvest to talk
on the job application he had written
that he was familiar with spanish german
and russian and then he had a pilot's
license okay
is that just basically i don't know i
couldn't find any it's something he said
so who knows right
around this time he decided he wanted to
start traveling and to see quote the
dark corners of the world
now i'm more of like hey what's hawaii
like what's costa riga like where
shouldn't i go
i put in trivago i didn't find anything
places not to not visit
where should i
where's it tough to see what's really
bad what do people hate i want to go to
a place that's really really awful i
need a place where i want to leave i'm
just trying to appreciate my bed
do you have anything to make me just cry
the whole time i'm there and feel dread
how can i live in the ocean
so
he sees a commercial for tours of the
soviet union huh and then
books a trip to the legend seeing those
commercials now i know i just can't i
also can't imagine
i mean i wish
if you weren't around then how [ __ ]
crazy the right wing was about like
russia and and you know reagan out of
his [ __ ] mind
so the fact that there were ads on that
you go there is yeah amazing
senator he goes to leningrad moscow
come to russia show people around it's
not that bad see the good look at all
these things way better than your [ __ ]
all huh what your [ __ ] all come to
russia learn about adidas finally after
dinner i did the [ __ ] that's what adidas
stand for come to russia baby
number one country i don't know how many
songs beatles write about your [ __ ] hole
exactly
come to russia best place on earth
mother russia
do you want to feed beer to a bear it's
possible sky's limit
come on none of the systems you want
blue jeans that rip
that what the grip
that reap yes like the grim reaper
really well sure whatever you want just
get in bus come on [ __ ] face we don't
have all day scared get in the goddamn
bus okay i'm going to russia why are we
taking a bus to russia he's fine
don't worry we're going to russia new
jersey it doesn't make any shut your
[ __ ] what you are all prisoners what
the [ __ ] just happened this is con air
but russia and bus continues
what what movie are you watching
so he goes to leningrad moscow totally
fine and he goes to turkmenistan which
is really a goddamn nightmare okay
turkmenistan is like what if trump was
crazy
sorry what if trump was crazy i mean the
dude the dude at one point
and there's a new guy who's oh you mean
there's a but a guy was like okay no
more dogs you can't have dogs on the
capitol like he just did [ __ ] like that
then the next guy came in and was like i
love dogs i made a statue for a dog
someone's like everybody has a dog it's
it's really now you must all have dogs
it's
i mean we could do a whole podcast about
trick man it's really it's okay
i recommend people just go read a
wikipedia about it so anyway he also
around this time starts putting his
russian language skills to work by
answering ads for russian brides in the
back of singles magazines
okay that's how you meet ladies that's
he's not good with the ladies so he
needs to i do i understand it it's just
like come on that's not good
i knew a guy when i was working at a i
was working in workman's comp and and
there was an older guy there and
his wife got a job at the place and she
was filipino
very young
he's like old and heavy and balding and
nothing attractive about him and she's
like young and hot
and she was clearly had a boyfriend on
the side and then it turns out like yeah
she was a
male-or-bride situation that's so weird
it was really cool and she had three
years to go before she could divorce him
it was like a countdown happening okay
you didn't have to put a clock in the
bed
so um yeah to me it's a weird thing like
you're sure you could fall in love that
way um it's still just just because of
the way we've i'm skeptical the way
americans the way we do things it's so
alien to us and yet there's a bunch of
dudes that do it i'd like to order a
wife
it's also like
like jeffrey is a guy who can't meet
he's terrible with friends he can't meet
them and then and then you there you go
yeah i mean okay well i mean honestly
like well yeah i won't i don't know
enough
i mean there's these women want out like
they want to share yeah whatever i'm not
going to sit here and [ __ ] critique
it i just i agree
uh so jeffrey had
at some point joined
a baptist church
and through the church in 1996 he was
part of dayton's friendship force by the
way they did some great stuff good
friendshiping yeah at like a four like
can you imagine a friend like a
friendship force i would be like listen
you get pack your [ __ ] tent up and
get the [ __ ] out of my face where your
friend
they're a for they're like a space force
but for friendship yeah you're under
arrest you're now our best friend the
[ __ ] that's how friendships work yeah
now we're going to hang out so this
friendship let's play rummy what let's
play rummy together i don't want to play
running let's play connect four i don't
want to do it come on you're part of the
friendship force and we're not leaving
until you have a good time i don't enjoy
it hope it's a paddle ball no how about
some tennis no how about connect four
again no have you played connect four
yeah very forceful connect four's full
is what i am and let me tell you a
little something about connect four have
you played it
yeah do you know the deal
yeah i know what's the point of the game
what what's the point get the four in
what what do you mean in get the four in
a row yeah yeah
what don't we have in common pal
everything gosh
i can't imagine my life before you
walked into it i can and i do all the
time let's get jackets that's not the
other's name i don't i don't even know
you this is very aggressive you will go
to jail if you're not my best friend
this is crazy aggressive friendship and
i'm not going to jail no one's going to
arrest me there's no cop that's going to
be like hey you're not this guy's friend
hey go ahead go in
okay bye bye
you missed me no
miss man walk the other way i was going
this way before so i'm going to go the
way i was going to go you can turn
around if you want to go friend pal okay
go the other way all right me too no
let's go to town
[Music]
so he's part of dayton's friendship
force that went to croatia and sarajevo
oh my god
we're looking to be your friends we
don't care when it ends we're friends
it's friendship come on grab a hand grab
a hand and make a friend it is never
going to end we're friends
all right croatia
hey
yeah hey
all right let's get back on the plane i
think we've lost our brain
well here's the crazy thing so the
bosnian
war i was gonna say peace plan
they did peace accords in dayton ohio
what yeah
that's where it was like all resolved
that
so okay so we are at the dayton marriott
uh relieving tensions between nations
continental breakfast
you walk into a wrong ballroom with
ballroom three
this wedding this one for wedding this
johnson wedding this is johnson
by the way get the satay
so like i said jeffrey is fascinated by
other countries and he's obviously
traveling places and then he became
very interested in a country called
north korea
when a famine hit the news in the
mid-90s
welcome to buzzwords
now in 1998 he signed up with an agency
that paired american women with ladies
in other countries that paired a women
american women or men
american men with women up in other
countries and uh they sent him a catalog
oh my god i mean that i mean i again i'm
trying to relate it to like dating apps
and it's not it's not that much
different it's not
uh so he picked some russian women and
one iranian woman okay
and uh started writing them okay and he
made a connection sure with one and for
like a year he wrote to this russian
lady tatiana schum
we'll start calling tanya because that's
what she goes by okay and he goes to
visit her she's 15 years younger okay so
he's about 40 she's about 25. um
and then a couple months later he goes
back to see her again
and then she flies back with him to the
u.s in july
uh she has to marry him within 90 days
or go back
i'm a [ __ ] idiot and there's surely
people who watch that show i'm pretty
sure that's what 90 day fiance is oh is
it i'm pretty sure it's basically like
something like that where yeah they fly
out and they see how it goes and yeah
you know
have you seen naked and afraid that's
just me running around with a bat
bro you don't get to talk about nate you
know i swear to god naked and afraid as
a dating show and i was like guys oh
come on come on
remember what made the brand good
they're like now naked and afraid
couples cooking yeah
uh so
they get married on day 91 september 20
2000.
she gets his job as a hair stylist they
start having kids they have three kids
in four years geez they go to church
every sunday
jeffrey quote you don't hear the term
mail order bride anymore i guess guys
are ashamed to call it that nowadays but
i never understood the stigma myself
okay okay yeah
if it works yeah sure and this seems to
work so jeffree star and that seems to
work forever we're happy or for a while
they seem to they seem to be doing fine
okay um jeffrey started spending hours
online looking at human rights reports
in north korea as you do you know what
else what else do you do online well i
mean to be fair if you're going to look
up north korea may as well start around
there the human rights yeah
he read books
uh about the experiences of north korean
refugees like escape from camp 14 and
only beautiful please and
then
jeffy traveled alone to russia in 2013.
okay
so he also when he goes on these when he
goes on these trips
he likes to go alone he likes to be
alone
and when he's there he tells tanya that
he's going to try to get into
mongolia okay
now mongolia is a demo democracy so i'm
not exactly sure what the at this point
it's a democracy so i'm not exactly sure
what the thing was but she begs him not
to she's like don't don't do this
because maybe he didn't have permission
and that might be it sure anyway guards
caught him trying to walk across the
border one morning at 2 a.m okay i mean
i like that that's your when they're
closed
the borders are the opposite of bars
they open at night so
the guards were like you could die
because you're walking in the middle of
nowhere huh it's not what
oh no what did you guys i'm looking for
my keys
that's just a
just miles and miles of nothing that
you're walking into like it's cold may i
go
no you'll die like we don't want you
you're just walking you don't have i'm
on a quest to find my car keys they were
here and i had them here well this is
not how you do it have you guys seen a
set of keys anyone hand in any keys no
for a ford
no for a maybe a an ambassador rambler
that seems like it's real okay all right
um okay well i'll just go this way then
while you're walking you're walking
backwards
[Applause]
so the next day he got on a bus full of
italian tourists and went into mongolia
hey it's a family time
okay
there was no more about that story he
just it's just like he's he's determined
to do things and he does them but it
also seems like he in that circumstance
he's determined to do things like the
foolish bad way well yeah because it's
not um
you know like i said i looked up
mongolia and they had like a democratic
revolution and their democratic
country's going there yeah i mean it's
not like it's hard to do he was just
like they were just like do you want to
take the bus tomorrow he's like um
sounds like a trap they're like it's
really not if you have a passport yeah
you just buy a bus ticket
rather dig if you walk it's like 80
miles to the next uh
what's that in bus town
so
he comes back
and
when he gets back he's his his thirst
for traveling is not quenched
and he starts looking into travel
agencies that do tours of north korea
wow here we go again
it's just it's not on most people's
vacation hot spot list although i am
super intrigued and i would do it in a
heartbeat i would absolutely go but i
mean it would not i would never be like
i'm gonna get that like someone would
have to be like you want to go and be
like [ __ ] yeah i'll go yeah i would love
to go to north korea those grocery
stores where you're just like this is
just a picture of soup
[Laughter]
and then one day he bought korean for
beginners on amazon so he's thinking
about the language sure right
and while he bought that book on amazon
the site made a suggestion for another
book oh no
a korean english study bible
oh he was like bible korea my passions
and it's turquoise colored
is it an actual translation of the bible
it is a yes it's a okay well it's i it's
a i think it's a way to study english
using the bible uh way to study korean
using the bible oh wow okay
right so
awesome what a
yeah
i've got to shop for it's
how you learn that's how i learned
amazon's followed up is amazing do you
want a korean bible
so yeah okay
so
he had read that north korean school
teachers sometimes recruited kids
to find christians who were hiding out
because it's illegal to be a christian
there okay quote go home and look for a
shiny black book with strange writing on
the cover bring it to school tomorrow i
wish we did that here yeah well we yeah
based on what's happened recently it's
time yes
the state department
warns americans not to
travel to north korea but it's not
forbidden you can go it's not like cuba
which would be right what a horrible
thing that would be if we could go down
there and be tourists and and uh
disgusting oh my god but then those
people would have money and they'd be
able to survive and you know
don't revolt against us otherwise you
end up on the naughty list that's right
let us do what we like yeah that's the
policy
uh so north korea allows tourists but
only an authorized group america just
shows like if america were a person it
would just show up to parties it wasn't
invited to eat everything and then when
it got kicked out be like the [ __ ] is
your problem
[Applause]
i don't know you
so you can only go in authorized groups
if you go to korea you can't just travel
there and walk around one please i would
like to walk around your country
demilitarized zone this is cute
so about 8 000 people traveled there
from western countries in 2014 so not a
lot but you know still
jeffrey tells tanya he wants to go
okay
she's not surprised based on his past
well she's also like well when you were
reading the north korean bible i was
kinda
the yikes the flag
so he books a 10-day trip run by koryo
tours a company out of beijing they're
the best awesome
it costs four thousand dollars okay not
that much i know but still any i that's
the problem with my mind and travel
booking
i just can't the idea of parting with
four grand for ten days
yeah okay yeah
um
the the way it would work is they'd
start in beijing that all the whole
group would go and meet in beijing and
then
uh go to quote famous ornate pyongyang
metro okay to the famous metro
they would also see quote parts of the
country never before seen by foreign
eyes and many ways that's horrifying
this is where everyone really lives in
the underground cell
we don't normally show people
but obviously not true because there's
other people that have taken the tour
right yeah right right right so besides
them
besides those foreign
you're the first ones
uh so jeffrey pax he's packing his
suitcase and tanya comes in and sees the
turquoise bible
and asks him to please not take that
right because it's illegal right
but
if he did
need to take it
she said leave it in beijing put it up
your ass and put up your [ __ ] ass put
it in a balloon and swallow it
and i want pictures
uh so leave in beijing before you go to
north korea right
tanya quote it was like he didn't even
hear me he seemed so distracted so
focused like he was packing for some
important mission sure yeah i'll take it
to north korea babe don't worry
yeah i got you i'll take it with me
don't worry i'm not gonna leave in
beijing that would be crazy why would i
do that i'm crazy i get it
well he was also focused on something
else at the moment because he was
putting a deflated basketball into his
suitcase honey you're distracted i'm
trying to get all the air out of this
[ __ ] thing could you just give me a
minute
gosh this is just i'm trying to you i
understand how hard it is to get the air
out of a spalding
by the way getting air out of the
basketball only way to do it is to put
the pin in and be like yeah that's the
only way you can yeah okay so i think
you can also reverse the way a pump
works sometimes uh if i recall correctly
i think that's on sex only
welcome to guy oh god you listen to all
things comedy
um
so he it turns out he had
he had gone to a harlem globetrotters
game when they came to dayton a few
months before those guys were so good
and he got they beat the [ __ ] out of
that other team
he got them all to sign the basketball
hey guys i'm 40. can you will you sign
this not for my son this is all for me
no he told them
that the ball was headed for north korea
hey guys i need you to sign this i'm
going to take it to north korea i'm
going there soon i'll take a bible my
wife's living guys we're all the same
age will you sign my ball
he told them his dream was to present to
kim jong-un ideally what i'm going to do
is give it to the dictator of the nation
um the man who is known for imprisoning
citizens for any sort of talk that he
doesn't like uh and killing people
indiscriminately i want to give it to
him
guys sign it to kim it's a man's name
it's different i know but i'm going
there
oh i love basketball baby i've got a
great idea not only am i taking the
bible but i'm taking this globetrotter
ball
and you were worried you're such a
warrior
so jeffrey also put a photo of his
family i'm not gonna take clothes i
think it's just the ball the bible and
the pictures of you guys and then i'm
packed
and this chair and this chair
and this rocking chair just will not get
in
so jeffy puts a photo of his family
inside the bible and pax it that way
they'll know who you are they could come
kill you because you're associated with
it you've got to catch it yeah yeah
the one that you gave me
uh oh the family yeah show a picture of
the family so gareth can see
how everybody looks so that's the family
oh that's him huh yeah
well yeah they look the kids look
russian
yeah and he looks like he's the kind of
guy who takes a bible to north korea he
does he really really [ __ ] does i
don't believe in consequence
[Applause]
well my my impression and i think you
can think about this as the story goes
on i think he's really [ __ ] dumb
i think he's a dumb man
i don't think he's bright
nice guy let's see where the story goes
it's not too bad let's see where the
story goes i have a feeling once kim
jong-un sees this bible
and this globetrotter ball he's going to
be on board
that's what happens they find the bible
then you go oh but i also they go what
what the bible
oh geez so
he puts the picture in
he also writes his family's names their
address and phone number in there
his plan is to he's going to drop the
bible somewhere in the northern
territories he's going to drop it yeah
he's literally going to drop it
okay
he
he figures
that
up in the northern territories the area
is far away from pyongyang which is
obviously the you know maine
capital and all that um and up there
christian undergrounds you know people
who are underground christians hiding
from the government and
doing their christian stuff well they
would find it and then they could use
the bible and his bible could be used by
an entire community i and because he
included his name and address and a
photo as a family the entire community
would know who brought it to them my god
it's a good idea
i mean the frogs leap less
that is unfucking believable
and he also
is basically just trying to get the
bible experience that's already been had
for his own he's basically trying to be
like i wrote the bible basically yeah
he's basically moses with the
commandments yeah he wants to be like a
guy who did something really important i
talked to god he said get this there's
an amazon receipt in here take that the
[ __ ] out don't come on that really takes
some of the shine off
it's you know what it reminds me of it
reminds me of when you're a kid and
you're fantasizing about you know making
that last shot
right or hitting the home run
yeah right
but for him this is his fantasy
yeah
like that's his version of this oh my
god tom he dropped the bible right in
between those bushes there's no way
any of the guards are going to be able
to find that that is purely going to be
found by the citizens outside of
pyongyang a whole community is now
christian based on this one guy this is
this is a seed that will provide harvest
for decades and generations
unbelievable stuff here from our crazy
jeffrey it's just it's it's he's the
michael jordan of batshit bible drops
it's really [ __ ] crazy it's crazy
it's crazy it's all crazy but it's crazy
to have never gone there no it's illegal
and have this plan that just involves
like if someone were to be like hey
don't take drugs into a country and you
got the drugs into a country and then
you were like now i drop them yeah like
wait what yeah no it's
you did the hard part if someone told
you this you'd be like what
yeah wow
no why would you do any of this by the
way like there's not one bible in the
country
right i mean they've never seen the
bible if you're if you're a christian
and you're in these
northeastern territories yes and you're
hiding from the government you guys have
got all kinds of [ __ ] [ __ ] work by
the way why don't you do what the bible
did and just rewrite the [ __ ] thing
just go into like mountains and be like
i'm pretty sure i know what it was let's
just translate it one more time the
bible is telephone
it is so
okay so that's the plan right good
and um
like i said it's insanely illegal to
have a bible i i want to put that out
there it is insanely illegal to have a
body i'm enjoying having mistakes reset
just
um and so his plan was if the bible did
if it was found by authorities
he would just say he accidentally left
it oh that's dropping oh i draw oh i
dropped my bible right
what which everybody does you [ __ ]
drop a bible once in a while you know
the bibles i've dropped on a trip oh man
i don't even think i've ever even held
one
so
uh since he had the cream put it in the
hotel drawer
i'll start a whole revolution
so since he had a korean language
workbook also he'd say the bible in the
workbook was how he was learning
korean and you know oops i dropped it
foolproof
so on april 2014 he flies to beijing
there's three dozen tourists in this
group
the guide's name is simon cockerell now
hilariously i went and looked him up
he's still
doing it still doing it okay
uh he'd been a north korean tour guide
for years his company was partnered with
korea international travel company kitc
which is run by the north korean
government so they're oh so there's
they're in partnership with the north
korean government but everything i've
ever seen as far as like somebody going
into north korea is it's basically that
you basically have a
propaganda like a state propagandist
yeah with you yeah so that anytime
you're asking questions and it's all you
know like well why is that like that
it's like oh well the dear leader like
so it's not like someone's like well the
real deal is yeah no that doesn't happen
no
so the total rules were quote no
unauthorized photography no off-color
remarks about kim il-sun his son kim
jong-il or current supreme leader kim
jong-un and no pushing
outside ideas on north koreans all right
so basically probably don't talk keep
your [ __ ] keep your [ __ ] [ __ ] just
zip it up don't just don't talk [ __ ]
just enjoy it take it down don't talk
[ __ ] take it talk [ __ ] when you leave
so then they all fly to pyongyang and
jeffrey has the bible
in a leather bomber jacket
which causes the whole jacket to sag to
the right
well that's what the bible did to our
political culture
so
he's got an in it's an inside pocket
right
that like snaps so he's got it in there
and the whole thing is just like
leaning one way
in the airport terminal a security agent
looks through his luggage
and jeffrey's like saying to himself
just trust in god this is what god's
plan just trust in god
and then he walks through the metal
detector and the metal detector goes off
jesus christ
he takes everything out of his pockets
except obviously the bible
and
the metal detector still goes off oh my
god what if he ha what oh my knife in
the bible i mean if it's like he takes
off his belt
it still goes off
so he thinks i'm [ __ ] i have nothing
else on me
and he reaches into the jacket to unsnap
the bible but then right then the
security agent tells him to just go
through
because
god is helping him right
sorry it took so long there sometimes
people confuse a security agent being
lazy with god helping them yeah
and in this case
god helped him
so
he goes about he goes on the tour bus
he sits alone everyone else is like
talking but he's just hanging he they
said he sat alone and smiled a lot so
again oh that's always a good thing to
see
i wonder why nobody sat next to that guy
can you imagine someone looking inviting
on a bus like looking like hey sit here
it'd be like absolutely not that's the
guy's gonna like poop
uh at the hotel they all had roommates
so he's paired up with the canadian dude
that poor bastard this is actually the
part of the tour where you lose me
yeah i'll for sure y'all for sure no
roommates yeah
um especially not him you might meet
someone who's like hey man you want to
get drunk and be like all right cool
instead this guy's going to be like
should we pray together hey you know
that this is all part of god's plan that
you and i would end up in room 902 yeah
i don't i i just wanted to not talk that
was my thing about the torah god's plan
involves us communicating no i yeah yeah
i'm gonna go and disagree i'm not a god
guy you know what i mean well i'm not a
god guy i don't believe in god i
don't believe in him
i can't say it i was gonna try to
convince you but why don't you get on
your knees
no get on this pillow okay
sit on the pillow on your knees are we
having sex huh no good lord no
no we're praying well i thought we were
gonna have uh
okay
be a sin of many ways yeah
[ __ ] yeah i would especially the way i
do it okay let's just go our separate
ways
so they spend some time in uh pyongyang
i just lay in bed and smile okay
so they spent some time in pyongyang he
his plan again is it he's going to drop
the bible plan is to just on his walk
drop the bible in the north in the
middle of nowhere northeast territories
right uh he's thinking ham hung or
shenzhen and uh he
he read human rights reports about
persecuted christians in chiang jin
so they've been sent to prison they've
been executed by having morton molten
law iron poured on themselves like
probably [ __ ] [ __ ] stories but
still is that gonna make you be like
maybe i just don't do the bible part
how'd they kill him molten
but reading that he thinks well these
people
didn't deny that they were christians so
there's there's probably a serious group
of dedicated christians up there how
about take one tour without the bible
then come back with the bible yeah yeah
yeah
now simon has specifically told
jeffrey the opposite right he said
people are really conservative
in the northern territories and they do
not trust foreigners there okay so he in
other words is he going to the worst
spot to do this yes okay so his plan was
to go to the spot where they would be
most open to it but because he i guess
was like just looking at the
globetrotter ball when he was given
direction he's now going to the place
where you don't want to be doing it yeah
he's taking the communist manifesto to
oklahoma
like
okay
so
there's a lot of they're they're on a
train you know and um again he still
thinks god's on the side and sure
they're taking a train through the
country there's security watching them
right there's always people around sure
he figured he should drop the bible
sooner rather than later together yeah
like home yes
so at a huge railroad station in onsen
he tried to
get a loan to drop but he could never
get a loan he just couldn't get away
from people
so then the next stop is
just just so i'm clear on this a little
bit he there is a picture of his family
in the bible with their addresses that's
correct okay
like the dumbest part of this story is
that he put his [ __ ] name and picture
in the [ __ ] bike isn't that
and what was the rationale behind that
he would say he was that that and that
was gonna help him say oh that's mine i
i dropped it that's my bible
as opposed to just dropping a bible and
going i didn't bring anything right and
is he do is he doing that because he
wants credit
he wants he wants the christians who are
going to use his bible
to then
get into honor him i guess or to be like
this is the man who brought us so again
i mean it is like it's what's always so
fascinating about the the
religious mentality or even the
christian mentality is like okay you
want to spread the message of god go do
it and he's like yeah but i want to be
remembered
that's right right you know yeah no if
you
like if you truly believed in this you
would just
get the bible in there and yeah
now yeah you just no credit [ __ ]
heaven off the train when no one was
looking
so the next stop is ham hung and um they
tore a fertilizer factory they went to a
lot of really great places that's
awesome this is where most of our [ __ ]
is
and they went to a theater still he
can't find a place
to drop it right
now the last stop was zhangjin and then
they were going back to pyongyang so
this is it like this is time
the tour group went to a pub in the
evening called the siemens club sure it
had once been for sailors but now mostly
just tourists okay
quote
and the quotes here um by the way are
you proud of me for not making a joke
oh yeah thank you yeah the quotes here
are unless i say otherwise are by joshua
hunt in
um atavist uh magazine which did a
really great story on this um hero okay
yeah
um
right so quote with a gift shop that
sold delicately
with a gift shop that sold delicately
arranged bouquets of dried fish
sorry what is that the siemens club
has a um dried fish club a no they have
a gift shop that sells dried food that
sells
arranged bouquets of dried fish right so
you get so instead of like flowers right
it's a fish situation right
right for your honey right yeah yeah no
for sure yeah i'm just trying to i'm
just thinking of
how um great great a gift it is yeah
yeah it's very great gift for sure
um
so jeffrey
sat there drinking ordered soda and
watching all his fellow tourists drink
and hang out and have a good time and
well he's just in his head like jeffrey
come on
bible time jeffrey so an hour in he
goes into the bathroom i'm gonna go take
the bible out
put my penis in the urinal
he figures not many tourists are going
to come through this area so
it could be a while before anyone came
into the bathroom and saw it
right he was thinking
put it in the bike in the bathroom
that's the plan it's a great plan
so he checks it out he checks out the
whole bathroom
go ahead let's just get his personal
information in there yeah yeah that's a
problem
so i mean at this point i would
goodfellas the bible and just like flush
it
[Laughter]
so he checks out the bathroom and then
he and then he doesn't do it he leaves
and he sits down i guess to think about
where he's gonna put
and a few minutes later he goes back
into the bathroom that's diarrhea
he goes into a stall and he takes out
the bible
be cool be cool god's with you be cool
god's with you be cool
i'm not
i'm real but this is a dumb plan
now
he had a newspaper
and he took out a
a page
and he wrapped the bible up the way you
would wrap up a gift
it just i
you've had so much time to think about
what you're gonna do
wrapping it like a gift again
it's just seemed it seems like it's
putting it seems like it's putting
another marble on the scale of
predetermination yeah it's not a good
move yeah
and then he puts it underneath a waste
basket
what like what and what is god god's
like in the quarterback of this place
yeah this is god so put it
under the trash can and wrap it in paper
all right lord you are mysterious
he thought
hiding it like that would give him time
to get out of the country before anybody
saw it but he's not really hiding it get
out of the i mean what like
i don't know i don't know what a fuse i
don't know what the waste basket
situation is like is it just sitting on
top of this book or
maybe he was able to slide it underneath
something so you couldn't really see it
i'm picturing he just put the bible
under the trash can and put the trash so
the trash can has like
about like an inch of daylight that's a
bible's worth of rise
so the trash has risen
and
he he's gonna deny everything if they
find it
well it's not like there's a picture of
my family in there with their home oh oh
oh oh
so he's nervous obviously what is giving
him nerves right now dave
i don't know okay because this is all
god's planning right yeah right
so they spend that night at the by the
way when he did this there were two sets
of footprints so
they spent that night at the uh shangjin
tourist hotel
quote providing a great chance to
observe nighttime rail traffic and soak
up the city's industrial atmosphere and
just stress your balls off
so you're just like it's just a nice
night i mean
poor tanya
so the next day the group
goes to check out a candy and dinner
roll factory right and i love the places
that just i mean it's easy to make both
with the same machines and ingredients
i think it expanded the candy empire
what are you gonna do gum no
rolls bread rolls
but it didn't really seem like a working
factory because none of the conveyor
belts were working and the candy and
dinner rolls which were just in piles at
the end of the belt
[Music]
great perfect
so outside in the parking lot
simon
speaks he gathers the tour group
and he says quote did anyone leave
something at the siemens club last night
all right let's say wagons west
one man jokes yes i love three thousand
dollars
gary they all laugh and then others pile
on
and make jokes that he had left his
bible yeah
yes imagine
simon's not amused
and everyone realizes this is actually
serious
and after a bit jeffrey said quote i
think i forgot my book
dude what this guy's not thought like if
you're gonna do this you need to this is
locked up abroad with the bible so you
need to be thinking about every step of
this what is what are you going to say
what are you going to do yeah you know
if you're going to put it under a trash
can does it really make sense you maybe
hold on to it should you maybe throw it
in the trash
but instead and then when it comes to
this i would be like i don't know what
you're talking about but then again if
you had a picture of your [ __ ] family
and you're dressing you'd be like hey
it's mine
i mean
it's just he's really painted himself
into quite a biblical corner do you
remember what i said moses couldn't part
this problem and walk through it
everyone said he might be dumb yeah
so
a very pissed simon asks him
what kind of book i don't know
and jeffrey says quote a turquoise book
my bible
and everyone in the tour group's like
bro yeah everyone in the top book is
like what what the [ __ ]
one rule yeah this was pretty easy this
one
so
simon another guy and a kitc rep that
canadian guy's like room two myself
tonight's no roommate tonight he's gonna
die
so they pulled jeffrey aside and they
questioned him
and
the bible had been found immediately and
turned in because anybody who found the
bible is like [ __ ] is this a trick right
right like are they are they watching me
yes like no one is gonna take that bible
and be like oh cool i'm gonna keep this
hey i should read this
oh what a cute family
uh jeffrey was like i dropped it i
dropped it
wrapped i wrapped i dropped i wrapped i
wrapped it i dropped it in the newspaper
i tried to pick it up and accidentally
wrapped itself and then i kicked it
under a waistband that's passed my back
hurt and i couldn't get it i didn't want
to say anything to anybody and i didn't
say anything to anybody dried fish
bouquets i love dried fish
so
the guides go and talk to the kitc
people
and after their discussion simon tells
jeffrey that what he'd done was really
really stupid but he thinks it's worked
out
and that's a load up jeffrey's back he's
like
okay but what a dumb [ __ ]
okay
like that's where you're at all right i
gotta wait i'm gonna live for putting a
bible under a trash can
well not
but not even just from his but
he could have gotten these [ __ ] tour
guides right sure yeah right
that night they all go to karaoke
and jeffrey is dancing and clapping
along with the songs and having a good
[ __ ] time because he did it he
[ __ ] did it gareth but he didn't he
did it but they didn't he pulled it off
they found it it's like james bond no
it's not getting the girl
and the information no it's james wrong
killing the bad guy and getting back to
inc but nobody got the bible
it's yeah it worked i don't think that
it has
ask god
ah
i'm not i'm not ask god i'm not gonna do
that ask god just talk to you
she was like no ask her
yeah i said no
come on i've been asking her she's on
here shouting no i won't hear it all
that she's shouting no
dear lord it was it's a part of your
plan to send jeffrey in there with a
bible that nobody read ever oh yeah
that's
blasphemed that was god
so
at one point during this karaoke night
he saddles over to simon
and he goes what are the plans for the
rest of the door our last day or
whatever what are we going to do we've
had such an eventful day am i right
am i right and simon cannot believe him
he's asked yeah he says quote do you
want to sing time of our lives together
as a duet simon it's me jeffrey
simon says quote you really don't get it
do you
what
and now jeffrey's scared again
[Music]
the next day all the other tourists are
giving him dirty looks
and some are making comments to them
one asked him what the hell he'd been
thinking
jeffrey quote just shrugged and stared
back at me with that alfred e newman
grin of his god empty-headed
empty-headed
they take the train from uh shangjin to
pyongyang overnight and as they head for
the airport
jeffrey is reprimanded by the kitc man
okay
he's basically saying there's
consequences for what you do there there
are consequences okay
at customs jeffrey had to go through a
metal detector and they made him go
through it over
and over
and over and over again
but he clears customs
and they go out onto the tarmac to get
on the plane
and just then two large north korean men
wearing black pants and polo shirts walk
up
don't say a word and just motion for
jeffrey to follow oh god
he's put her to the back seat of a car
sitting between the two men
a man in the front seat turns around he
says he's named mr joe and he would be
jeffrey's interpreter hi i'm mr joe it's
a real name
so they go to this hotel that's a famous
hotel
wow and um they take jeffrey into a back
room
it's just of any of all the people to be
in this situation the guy's like
[Laughter]
mr jaws the bible in his hand and he
asked jeffrey if this is his um it's one
of my wife's there's a photo of his
family sticking out of the bible uh i'm
trying to think if that is minor isn't i
guess
here's what i'll say i have one that
looks just like it and that's my family
i have another turquoise bible
like that
that's not my family here's what i do
that's my brother there's a nice family
that's right that's mine and there's two
others like it i've stashed in this
country and if you want to find out
where they are you're gonna let me get
on that [ __ ] plane gentlemen
so
look his plan to say he dropped it is
just in [ __ ] ruins i dropped it
because he put it under a trash can and
wrapped in a newspaper
again no thinking like no on the feet
thinking
so
i mean literally the way he did it
there's no way it could be anything but
a guy
yeah yeah i mean he just completely
framed himself i mean even if it was
under the trash without the paper or if
it was just paper wrapped one of those
two maybe you could but together no no
so he cops to it he says yeah that's
mine
and then they take him to the 36th floor
of the hotel
you're going to meet god up here
two men go through his luggage and they
list every single thing in it
and then a military guy comes in and
said quote you are here under
investigation for this incident of
leaving a bible in the dprk
another man in a gray uniform comes in
and questions him about his work his
family his life he's like growing up
everything
and then at 30 minutes
uh it's like a a
switch flips and he starts interrogating
him
he was asked who was paying him who paid
him to do this oh man the lord
quote things will be much less pleasant
for you if you don't cooperate tell us
who gave you the bible tanya
she's behind the ball
she came from russia she's just hell
bent on getting it's been a 20-year plan
jeffrey said uh it was his idea and he
brought he bought the bible on amazon
i mean like it's just you would be like
i mean it's such a bad excuse that maybe
it's true or maybe it's brilliant
it's from amazon it's he's just so who
put you up to it it was my idea i bought
it on amazon
feels like
are we overestimating this guy
who do you work for my independent
contractor for the most part i bought
that bible on amazon
so it was magazine quote
foul tried to explain why he'd brought
the bible to north korea he told mr joe
and mr kim about his dream
and about his trip to the desert
dismissed and i woke up covered and come
and both men seemed baffled mr kim
looked vaguely disgusted
so you had a dream that it drizzled and
you brought a bible here that's right
so they're literally just like this guy
is so [ __ ] dumb yeah they're like sir
you might be able to get out of here
on
diplomatic imbecility okay
tell us
why you brought the bible
i was dreaming that i was looking down
at a revival and i was thinking bad
thoughts about them and then god came up
behind me and said no they're good
listen to them and then i was we asked
you was
why did you bring it i'm getting there
and god said who what did he mean
i have a plan and you're part of this
plan so i go to the desert are you sure
it was god it feels like you would have
a much better park
what and i take a bed roll uh-huh i
leave the title and the note on the car
whoever wants the car can have it
abandon your car happy car i said just
so you had a blanket and i take my bed
roll bed roll and i take my bed roll and
i walk off into the desert we actually
have a factory that makes bedrolls and
cans four days uh-huh
four days right sure
and then i come back out and what i
gotta i got and then i'm on it did you
get back in the car okay so that was the
car there yeah the rangers had taken the
title and put it back and said don't do
this so they're basically like you're an
idiot and so i does everyone just think
you're an idiot and so and listen and
then i i'm on amazon and i'm buying a
how to speak korean thing uh-huh and
then this turquoise bible comes up and
i'm like oh my god how who could do this
but god amazon does because all that
that's their whole thing
no they target you because you bought a
korean book they were like hey let's see
if this dumb [ __ ] wants to buy a
turquoise bible okay
but how did amazon know about the dream
and the desert they didn't they're just
like it's their whole thing is they
collect data they've been collecting
data on you
what's in your head so how do feathers
how did they know that though
you know what i mean it's part of the
it's because it's what it's designed to
do
anyway let's say you buy it then you
brought it here
you really just
it's like
talking to a uh figurine it's like a
hubble
there's nothing inside your melon is
there
the pillow was so wet stop talking
be a great uh thing for us to say
so these two korean gentlemen say look
you're not being forthcoming
and we are going to take you to where
quote the facilities won't be as
accommodating and the interrogation
techniques will be harsher so his plan
is so dumb so dumb that he'll get
tortured that's what they're basically
like we can't believe that anyone's this
stupid so we're gonna find the truth out
and he's like i already told you the
truth that's so
yeah it's i mean look they they don't
take him anywhere and they just leave
him in this hotel room
um he turns on a tv and he sees on the
news there's another american matthew
miller who is also imprisoned in north
korea and they're talking about him
and then the next day they come and
some worker comes and now there's no
more foreign channels on the tv oh
so the state department is alerted to
what's going on
[Laughter]
sorry what did he do
sorry let me take you off the speaker
phone what the what did he do
so
uh the state department tells tanya and
she is like yeah i [ __ ] told him not
to go to [ __ ] north korea and i told
him not to bring the [ __ ] bible yes
every part of it i said no
uh the us government is like we're gonna
do everything we can to get him out but
it's obviously really complicated dumb
americans are americans too i mean could
you make up most of the country could
you imagine you're in the state
department and someone comes in your
office and tells you this [ __ ] story
sure we have uh something we might a man
might be killed in north korea he took a
turquoise bible and he wrapped it and
put it under a garbage can
we wanted to save him but now that i
hear it we probably shouldn't is this a
prank no no it's not the man um
appears to have no brain sir
so
let's can we just leave this guy like
that's our plan we said leave him but it
just we feel like
you know it's just like it's it's like a
six on this hand half a dozen on the
other i could really go either way
it's like a do i want paninis or panera
for lunch you know what i mean it's like
but both sound fine
neither is appealing
okay yeah we're just going to leave them
sorry but
are you good with panera that's kind of
yeah
okay great we're going to do a panera
uh
so whatever they're gonna try to get
them out they can't operation dumb [ __ ]
is initiated sir
they the family can't tell anybody
because they don't want anybody knowing
by the way the family won't tell anyone
because the family doesn't want anyone
knowing are you [ __ ] kidding me tanya
please don't reveal this to your
neighbors uh please do not reveal to
anyone else too please let's keep tight
lid on it
if people knew it would be easier for
north korea to use them for propaganda
purposes a bargaining chip and whatever
yeah plus we never invited the block
party last night
so a week after jeffrey was detained
north korea learned
uh there was a movie in production
called the interview in which james oh
[ __ ]
oh my god
i'm sorry i don't know either of those
actors well it's not good for you buddy
uh i don't know what to tell you it's uh
you're here at uh by the way we're gonna
make you not believe in god by the end
of the month that's the plan
so you know seth rolling and james
striker would try to assassinate uh kim
jong-un um so seth rogen a great guy
james franco like rapey yes so so rapey
that seth rogen is like
yeah he should uh go away so north korea
said there would be a quote merciless
response and that the film was an act of
war yes yes i mean if i i remember very
vividly that time being like things have
changed this is a new
the hack all that like you were like
this is next level the insult that was
very weird a movie that can't be
released in theaters i mean i don't know
if they still are but for years sony was
not communicating by email and like
their whole system was [ __ ] well yeah
because everything they were just like
oh bradley cooper can suck it
i'm sorry bro
bradley i was it was i wish there was a
sarcasm font
so sony delay's release of the film
weeks go by each day a minder would come
in
and
they would watch
in the morning they would watch exercise
tv shows who who jeffrey and his mind
yeah
and the minder would exercise and try to
get jeffrey to join in
which is so funny because that's always
like almost like stereotypical what you
hear about north korea yeah
it's true yeah it's like morning
calisthenics yeah yeah
although we could use morning
calisthenics here yeah uh was that a
pastry in the in the middle of the day
another reminder would come
his job was to get jeffrey ready for his
trial okay
jeffrey it's also mainly exercise based
and exercise based yeah jeffrey was told
to confess his crimes against north
korea and they wanted him to write them
all down like write everything he'd done
down
during these interviews jeffrey had to
wear a dress shirt so when this guy came
over this minder he would put on a dress
shirt but he wasn't leaving the he just
had to dress nice for this guy
that's amazing
it's just my room please put on a nicer
shirt
sometimes discussions with this guy were
pleasant sometimes they were really not
pleasant and jeffrey just said over and
over and over that he'd come on his own
and know what it sent him
uh minder quote that's schoolboy logic
if you don't start cooperating things
are going to become less pleasant i mean
his plan is so dumb they don't believe
it's possible they don't know what to do
with it it's so [ __ ] yeah it's so it
really it's like a three-year-old's plan
of course
of course it sounds like he's lying
because it's so [ __ ] stupid yes and
they're and they're like look he's
clearly got great training we can't
break him and and even if he wasn't
lying they would want him to lie but in
this case they're like jesus christ come
on
after a while it was clear they didn't
want the truth so
that's what jeffrey says yeah right yeah
okay yeah why don't you not have
attitude for a little while jeffrey so
jeffrey invents a guy mr carter and he
said mr carter ran an underground oh mr
carter
can i take the bible it's so old
mr carter i used to watch nick at night
reruns okay yeah mr carter ran an
underground missionary in china and he
had gotten jeffrey to drop the bible off
the miner's like that's absolute
[ __ ]
that's just the dumbest then i brought
it on my own like i said for the past
two weeks
finally after three weeks jeffrey was
done writing his statement of guilt so
whatever they wanted him to write he
wrote up this thing
and then after he was done writing he
was taken to a guest house where he
would now be staying okay and when he
first got that there the first day he
read his confession out loud and after
was told to think about what he would
like to write to his family so they're
like you're going to get the right to
your family
so i went over and opened a desk drawer
and inside was a piece of paper with no
schoolboy written in block letters
across the top wow
so he's like
is this a message or did another guy
stay here
who had gone through this it's a message
yeah they're like but his thing was like
oh no someone must have stayed here it's
a sign
stop finding signs he generally he
generally thought another guy had stayed
there and i was like
he's writing me messages when i first
heard i was like no they wrote that i'm
gonna take this paper and put it in a
bathroom
this needs to be seen oh [ __ ]
so the state department would
talk to tony each week in filler room
with what was going on they said it was
gonna probably tell your husband's still
an idiot but this week uh basically
nothing yeah so they think it's gonna
take about six months to get him out um
i mean
she writes to all the ex-presidents who
are alive so clinton the bushes carter
i'm not interested in helping
oh he sounds like a dumb shirt i said
your husband sounds like a dumb [ __ ]
unfortunately ma'am your husband sounds
stupid and that's coming from me i'm
also stupid okay
well i fell well figure charges hopping
out but
the only way to do it build a habitat
for humanity bridge oh that was carter
that's me
[Applause]
i thought that was clinton no this is me
and i'm over here
i'm different
i'm a hammer okay my hands don't work
anymore
my hands work great i'll use them often
uh he only got she only got one response
w's office and a form letter yeah
thank you for reaching out to president
if you'd like to buy a painting please
attach 30 and we'll send you one of a
toad
now on june 6 the us government revealed
jeffrey was
imprisoned in north korea
crimes against thinking
for being a [ __ ] idiot
two japanese papers reported he was
arrested for leaving a bible in his
hotel room that just makes him sound
totally innocent and smart totally but
if you're him great get that out there
uh media just come pouring into his
hometown
a local jedi democratic congressman who
had been to north korea a few times said
he would look into it he told tanya
quote leaving a bible in a room is not a
big deal and shouldn't be a big deal
what if he wrapped it in paper put it
under a trash can with addresses in the
pictures of his family
also it is a big deal yeah that's their
rule big deal
yes
this is what i would relate it to i love
to smoke marijuana yeah whenever i go to
another country i don't bring marijuana
with me it's not because i don't want to
smoke marijuana okay it's because i
recognize that this is there's
there's international law and if i don't
want to be prosecuted for crimes i've
committed i'm not going to commit those
crimes okay counterpoint uh-huh
marijuana shouldn't be a big deal uh yes
great [ __ ] you that's my whole [ __ ]
neighbors can't believe that
nice quiet
jeff would do anything to get himself
thrown in jail no
one said quote a lot of people would put
up money if there was a jug at the
market
that'll do it
uh dear leader we have the jug
it's like it's like we're reading the
story and all of a sudden all of a
sudden someone's like i'm from america
in 1840 like what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah like
that's like what are you raising money
for a little league table trying to get
a man out of the
north korean prison
well we got about 45 how much is it
going to take to get him out
another said quote he's such a mild
mannered person that i can't imagine
anybody not letting him go
that's not how it works you don't just
that's not it's like every neighbor of a
murderer oh he just kept to himself
can't imagine uh
so papers interviewed people who had
gone to north korea like a guy andrew
lombardi he had gone in 2011. the
journal news quote
the trip lombardi said was eye-opening
compelling and occasionally fun like
when he played in the nation's first
ever ultimate frisbee tournament oh wow
hey hey andrew can i just
one favor yeah one favor go can you
[ __ ] stop talking about you playing
in the first ultimate frisbee tournament
why can you not squeeze it into every
single they were asking me what they
asked for my opinion on his situation
yeah but all you do is squeeze in when i
was first i barely i don't even remember
saying that what i said to him was let
me finish what i said to him was hey
yeah it was a great time i had a lot of
fun there uh i learned a bunch of stuff
and you know for all for all frolf
what for all for all false
what is
what frisbee golf frisbee golf jesus
christ what
all you it was [ __ ] 1978. it was 19
it was the fall of 78 which is basically
79 jr that was 50 [ __ ] years ago oh
my god get what are you the human
calculator nobody gives a [ __ ] about the
[ __ ] ultimate frisbee turtle okay i
was answering a question no you weren't
international law
does anybody do you have any friends
yes
the disc
jesus christ and my dog
just stop bringing it up dude
my life is like mark harmon and
summerslam
[Music]
another taurus cyrus kirkpatrick said
you were fine if you didn't quote bring
up topics about politics or other taboo
subjects and not bring in bibles or
other restricted what if you wrapped one
under the garbage
said strange what have you what if you
took one you rested really really really
clear about the thing they don't want
there okay but what if you wrapped it in
gift paper and said to all the korean
people from lord jesus christ and me
jeffrey
just don't see there's not a loophole
there's no bible loopholes what if i put
a ribbon on it no
nope
what if it was like a talking bible and
you open it up i think it's worse i
think the ideas are getting worse that's
worse really yeah
what if when you open it it explodes it
explodes into like 500 bibles that's uh
like a gremlin bible yeah i don't think
that's yeah you get it wet and it just
turns into more bibles worse bibles well
i mean
bibles that hurt people no that's the
original
it seems very
restrictive and dumb rules
it should be you should be able to leave
a bible wherever you want uh no not if
the country says you can't so
um so
his kids were writing him letters but
you know they didn't you're dumb dad i
keep doing it they didn't i didn't know
if he'd get him to try to distract the
kids tanya bought some chickens great
so maybe you know your father has a
smaller brain than most of the birds
he's crazy
i mean maybe there's just a simplicity
that goes through the whole family
what's great is mother hens sit on an
egg much like trash can sit on the red
bible dumb [ __ ] take to an mk
he stopped talking about daddy like that
i'm not trying to but i'm just hoping
you don't inherit dumb [ __ ] i know comes
from your father's side and the gene
seems to be
predominant i don't like the chickens
anymore well listen i don't know what to
tell you you have a vacuum as far as a
parent goes and i
fill the void with a bunch of little
foul
okay now
each one of these is named dead
there you go
jeffrey started writing lists to
distract himself
things i regret
he wrote lists of beatles songs he wrote
lists of presidents he wrote lists of
motown songs and christmas songs he
would just write lists of everything
another list
here i go fun fun fun
list of cars
[ __ ] idiot so
on june 20th he was taken to meet the
swedish ambassador who had letters from
jeffrey's family so the swedish
ambassador is
it's kind of the country they end up
using
to deal with situations
so
um and uh his
sister-in-law jeffrey's sister-in-law
sent a week's worth of crossword puzzles
cut off from a local paper oh boy
move away lists there's a new game in
town only a [ __ ] week's worth yeah
well i mean are you [ __ ] kidding me i
think it'll take him a while to do it
wait what does it mean a cross why
didn't you give me six years before i
had a biblical reference a cross
a cross
telling you didn't write anything
okay [ __ ] tony didn't need to write
anything too yeah there's something
weird there but also she said it was
because she was from russia and grew up
under
a government in which people would read
whatever you wrote and she
hated that sure but also
what are you gonna say jeffrey was
allowed to make a collect call home so
he calls his family it costs 140 bucks
she had no money because her husband the
breadwinner was
i don't think he had a good plan i'm
just retrospect on everything fair it's
a fair
assessment so
um that same day june 20th north korea
began releasing statements about the
movie the interview
quote there's a special irony in this
storyline as it shows the desperation of
u.s government and american society a
film about the assassination of a
foreign leader mirrors what the us has
done in afghanistan iraq syria and
ukraine and let's not forget hey hey
take it easy come on relax
and let us not forget who killed kennedy
americans hey hey take it easy
hey i tell you we made some mistakes but
relax huh whoopsie poops
we didn't mean to kill kennedy we're
trying to just puncture the tire
uh by the way that's the problem with
having to represent the united states
we are we just want to negotiate so it's
like well you've uh you always kill
dictators well um you kill heads of
state you send in the cia to do like
coups off the record well but uh
mainly for oil well but listen we're
very awesome in many ways please
so the sony ceo asked rand corporation
for a threat analysis and sony was told
north korea would likely test sony's
computer systems
so jeffrey's health starts going south
he was having dizzy spells
he was seeing black spots in his
peripheral vision
and logic and logic and he was worried
he was being poisoned so he started
keeping his nail clippings and hairs
he took from his tub drain and he was
putting them in a napkin yep okay keep
going i'm just
next next portion of the story we're
ready for
because obviously uh yeah if you're
being poisoned you keep that in case you
want to test for poison later when he
goes home
so did you learn about bringing weird
[ __ ] in your suitcase yes will you test
my nails
here's four pounds here's four pounds of
my hand nails
they gave him a physical at a hospital
but no one asked about being dizzy or
the black spots
the swedish ambassador had given him a
hemingway book but they took it away
we're not letting him have books anymore
now this guest has his in the plumbing
doesn't really work um the power is out
all the time like 12-hour stretches
tv on the tv all propaganda
his interpreter said power was out a lot
but the interpreter was fine because he
now had solar like so all these people
in north korea are getting solar power
so they can deal with the
what we're dealing with what places like
texas so jeffrey was mostly
alone can you imagine being in a dark
place with propaganda and tv all the
time no
no okay no okay no i can't okay no no
okay
in early august he was taken to a press
conference
uh he tried to be positive because he
knew his kids would see it he wanted to
think everything was okay with him
they gave him talking points which he
forgot the interpreter had to tell him
what to say oh you're supposed to say
that
right
now after that interview they started
preparing him for the next
uh the press comments which was going to
be on september 1st
and on that day he was taken to a sports
complex and there were american
reporters waiting for him
jeffrey did not see him in good shape
now okay
he stumbled over his words quote there
was a panic in his eyes
yeah
he told cnn quote i'm getting desperate
back home the city manager told
reporters if jeffrey didn't come back
soon he was going to have to fire him
wow
that ought to do it i mean talk about
leverage
are you imagine i can't believe he's
done his job i can't believe that guy
gave that statement
yeah we might have to move on
by the way even if he comes back move on
yeah
uh jeffrey was fired at the end of
september wow
but
they did say a job would be ready
waiting for him if he returned okay so
if he wanted it sure
on october 21st the interpreter came
with jeffrey's suitcases and started
packing his stuff
in about five minutes they were in the
car
he was token taken to a hotel conference
room full of north korean reporters
after 20 minutes a military guy comes in
and says quote the supreme leader and
first secretary of the workers party kim
jong-un has recommended that you be
released
jeffrey turns and starts babbling to
this guy who's in a uniform
about how much he appreciated please
tell him anything i mean i love i'll
jerk him off whatever he needs i'm
really really just way in he's saying
this is kim jong about kim jong-un yeah
he's really awesome i love it and the
guy's like dude i'm american shut the
[ __ ] up stop [ __ ] talking he's a real
[ __ ] isn't it you can talk me again
on a plane but shut your [ __ ] mouth
before you do something else right
so uh they take him out they get him on
the plane there's a doctor
can i have an aisle seat i hate that guy
i just
i'm happy to be here i'm happy to be
here i just
love sorry
so there's a doctor on the plane
and he sits next to him and i guess he
asks jeffy some questions and jeffrey
what brings you here
i created an international incident for
being done
jeffrey uh
tells him the problems he's been he's
been having and then he pulls out the
napkin
with all the nail clippings and hair can
you do me a fantastic doctor can you
analyze these in your coke
is that possible for some reason the
doctor didn't want them
why'd you hit the stewardess
why are you calling over the flight
attendant i'm not sure
i'll just take them back
sorry gosh
i tell ya
i think you know a passenger tanya
brings all the kids to the airports uh
she doesn't tell the kids why
interesting right well i mean i would
here's what i would say
this whole thing is so damn crazy that
if he's not there and you set the
expectation that he is and he doesn't
come because he's put himself in the
dumbest situation possible then that's
even more trauma for him that's not why
she did it okay go ahead
uh
i forgot his name
tanya wanted to surprise her husband
because quote i think jeff likes
surprises oh i don't know if he likes
all surprises
i feel like there's some that maybe
aren't great
yeah but that's not a that's not a
surprise for him it's you're surprising
the kids yeah also yeah right yeah he's
not being surprised at his family okay
okay
uh a army guy there said quote the
children knew something was up when the
airplane arrived and there were
television cameras so there's no
surprise yeah
cameron snapped pictures of his his
excited kids hugging him on the tarmac
a family attorney said they wanted to
quote thank god for protecting jeffrey
during his six months in captivity so
what's your reason what's your reason
what's your read on this deity your read
on this deity is what i can never get
past this [ __ ] it's nuts i can never get
past it nuts it never it never fails it
never fails you know what it reminds me
of always is when you're like hey the
climate is collapsing and we need to do
stuff and people like but you're talking
about getting rid of a whole sector of
jobs
yeah no earth will do that that's part
of it
people might be getting clued into that
now that the thing we've been talking
about is
if you don't change then climate change
is going to change you anyway so yeah
it's like whatever your knock list of
values are it's like yeah they don't
exist without air
uh
so
after a few months his headaches went
away his vision improved i feel like i
should go back
two bibles do it again
the city gave his job back
okay
uh he joked to reporters that he wanted
to go to pakistan next i'm just kidding
his boss was not amused all right okay
his new contract forbid him from
traveling to dangerous places or he
would be fired
fair clause
the other two detainees were released
two weeks after jeffrey sunday released
the movie the interview
was then hacked and tons of their
information released
the hackers discussed quote the movie of
terrorism
reflecting back on it jeffrey doesn't
feel like his amazing bible stunt had
accomplished anything and that god must
not have wanted him
to succeed
that's
it
that's your takeaway yeah
he's mysterious
that's why you can't say the lord works
in mysterious ways it's a cover for
everything
it's pretty bad
it's like if an alcoholic could be like
he works in mysterious ways no he's just
drunk he's just drunk guy
god damn like i said this is uh
mainly based on
holiday at the dictator's guest house by
joshua hunt in davis magazine also
uh the journal newspaper from hamilton
ohio and the dayton daily news from
dayton ohio
i mean that that is
that that that should be taught in
church
that story
he should have a hymn
i mean there's a there's a biblical
lesson it's in how not to operate and
and the line between
reality and your faith
you recognize you know
it's just
well it's this weird american arrogance
that happens where he's like and
religiously
and not just because it's that thing
where like you know white guy looks at
non-white people and goes oh i can
really save them well i don't think
that's ever happened but keep going but
but you know the the truth is if you
look at that situation you'd be like oh
if there's christians there they have
bibles already like they've got them
hidden away and they read them when they
can safely and this is a really [ __ ]
bad idea they just drop it in a [ __ ]
[ __ ] well it yes obviously not the
smartest or most uh tactical move but um
yeah but it's also if if a component of
religion is to spread it everywhere yeah
you know
then this is part of the bidding and
that's why
when
you see like there have all these stop
gaps that used to be there to stop
religion from permeating actual reality
yeah like because it the combination is
toxic
um
but now they're not so much and now it's
way less and now creationism gets taught
and you know they're like you don't want
to teach critical race theory but you
know let's teach um the fact that like a
man and a woman woke up in a garden
and they're the first two
you know
like
the reason is because it's it's called
faith because you're allowed to have
faith in it or you're allowed to not
yeah and so it's faith so you're putting
faith in this system that you believe in
and a lot of times reality is not able
to penetrate faith which is why we say
we don't want it involved in
institutions if you want to go home
you know it's a lot like smoking weed
she's like if you want to smoke weed
you'd you know go do it at home that's
like was the rule forever and everyone's
like okay compliant with that but
religion for some reason you can [ __ ]
smoke it on every street corner and blow
it in everyone's [ __ ] face throw lit
joints into cars you know just be like
hey bible bible
wow
sorry well i'm a christian so this is
pretty hard to hear no it's horrible
pretty hard i forgot about that part of
it and i'm also a mormon all right well
jeffrey was actually not a lot of people
know he was more mon
he was
uh [ __ ]
i just you read you read the stories of
people that are just so dumb and no one
ever says they're dumb but you're like
this is a dumb guy literally should be
taught in schools yeah the story should
take a day teach the story in schools do
what we just did
teach the story it teaches you about uh
manifest destiny it teaches you about uh
the religion it teaches you about idiocy
it's it's i mean it just shows you the
power that lives inside the head of a
white man yeah
and man i mean inside his brain he's
he-man
you imagine i would love to know where
he lands with all the stuff that's going
on now
like what what do you mean vaccines and
covet and all that stuff because we're
we're really living in a
in a world of chaos due to stupid people
well this is to what we were just
talking about and when i was saying the
like you lose a sector of jobs to
climate change it's the same with this
when you say
yeah the vaccine helps and people go you
can still get covered from the vet if
you have the vaccine right it's like
right so that argument has been totally
put to bed right we understand and
acknowledge that what what people
experience pride about having it is that
they're not going to die from it
but that like you're just not able to
machete through the jungle of nonsense
and get and and you know push push
actual reality through it it doesn't
work it doesn't work for part of our
population and now we have so little
trust in our government because the
government has been completely
obliterated over you know years in
private industry that people so
don't believe in government that when
the government says take a vaccine
people would rather go and find horse to
warmer or
by the way the horse the warmer is great
uh or or because you've never provided
people free health care right they don't
believe that they're ever going to get
anything for free right so it is that is
one of the things that is really amazing
about this time is the level of
misinformation but also the level of
distrust which comes from places that
where you actually can relate to and
empathize you know if you're if you're
brought up in places where people are
constantly getting screwed by medical
bills or people you know get [ __ ] by
the medical system or get screwed by the
government i mean this is like most
people
you know
it is
the it it the government would have done
themselves a much larger favor by not
trying to [ __ ] everyone for the last 50
years
and look there's another aspect of
what's happening this week which is i
think people a lot of people
in new york and other places are like oh
this is yeah really bad yeah oh this is
actually oh i didn't expect this
um yeah you didn't you didn't expect it
and now it's here and that's one thing
but let me tell you something
for um
for years we've been
taking
slashing government and so government's
not building things and
you know you give it to private
companies through contracts so so now
you have a situation where um the
government's been slimmed down so much
and
now you have to rebuild all these places
in new york
well
the problem is that people are going to
profit off that and when you have an
entire segment of society that profits
off climate change you have a problem
yeah it's why it's not just the fossil
fuel makers it's the guys who yeah now
it's ever the people who make the
bridges the people who you have a real
[ __ ] issue now it's why privatization
is really bad yes and why the idea that
we are controlled by money and the goal
is to get as much money as possible
always is completely
it's just not a sustainable goal it's
not just so we have we have this system
that we live under
that is where we're openly openly pretty
much admitted that both of the parties
that represent us in this country both
are bought
so
we keep going
well i know the others this side's crazy
and nobody's not acknowledging that the
right is not totally [ __ ] bonkers
it's just that in lieu of them because
they left the republican party and went
far right
the democrats went to the republican
party and now there's no left and that
is the only way to solve any of this
stuff is to go in that direction but
people are so fearful of the far far
right part that they're willing to sit
in the middle right part because it's
less terrible
and neither one are you ever actually
given or granted a [ __ ] thing and
unfortunately with climate change you're
going to go right
unless you address it that will lead to
authoritarianism yes it's i mean it's
how are you gonna fight how are you
gonna fight fight
how are you going to maintain our
society if there's
four of these floods a year in new york
city and for these hurricanes in
louisiana and these fire if they're all
going on at once how are you going to be
able to
fund anything how are you able to do
anything that's what we're facing like
you have to sort of
realize like the reason you need a green
new deal is because if you don't it's
going to be a really bad black deal it's
selfish it's selfish it is it is totally
it is what it's what i mean people
should want i mean people should
absolutely it should be the it should be
the only thing you [ __ ] give a [ __ ]
about right now
and the and the democrats you know i
mean look biden is
saying he's you know the ipc report
comes out and he says yeah we're gonna
we gotta do something right since the
thing and three days later he's
literally telling yeah
he's saying he's he's giving out leases
all the place and you're like yeah it's
not you can't talk out of one side of
your face and then do the opposite
we don't have those options it's not an
option it's not a yeah no it's i mean
again and especially what you're looking
down the barrel like
i mean you know look
you're
a revolution start very quickly so it's
not like so you can be like okay like it
looks like we're you can be defeatist
and it's understandable but
you know the problem is that these two
parties really the duopoly is so
controlled by companies i mean even when
they i'm [ __ ] rambling but that you
see that that the bp interview with that
dude that got released where the guy
worked for bp and he was he was it was a
project veritas veritas they they did
the undercover interview with this exxon
guy
and
he's basically letting it rip because he
thinks he's applying for a job in
another job and he's basically saying
like yeah no the whole thing we're
supposed to do is to convince people
that we are trying to change things yeah
and then we really don't do anything and
then the clock runs out on that and then
you have a new administration and it is
it's it's a it's a really good plan if
your plan is to [ __ ] ruin everything
and make all the money you know it's a
really good plan and that's what they
have is a really really good plan and
then the people us we don't have the
plan we don't have the power to have the
plan so until you actually get in people
who are like [ __ ] this system and again
they don't exist in either of these
[ __ ] parties unfortunately
it's just gonna be more the same and
it's never gonna change and the only
thing that you can feel better about is
that there's a worse party and that's
what that that's how they both survive
they both survive by saying you don't
want the other one they promise nothing
there's no offering a great example is
you know texas making abortion illegal
and then you know the democrats first
response is to send out fundraising
emails i mean that's that you know
there's there are things that the party
could do they could you know the housing
crisis they they have control of all
three branches of government so they
could
do stuff but but then you know everyone
yells at like well we're out later and
you're like you have control of all
three branches of government like yes
and you blame you blame not being able
to put 15 minimum wage a thing that is
enormously popular on the senate
parliamentarian a position that most
people unheard of i mean it's basically
you were just like we have the numbers
but there's a senate wizard we didn't
know about you know wait what it's like
the wizard said no it's like wait who
the [ __ ] an unelected wizard denied it
yeah and tell people like
instead of screaming it the people
who voted wrong
if you instead screamed at your actual
party who was not doing enough with
climate and everything else and i'm
sorry and and also you know the abortion
issue they haven't done enough they're
not they scapegoated they escaped they
made it they made it so that they they
they i mean that's the same thing with
the eviction moratorium the way that
they played that like oopsie poopsie who
did this it's like get a [ __ ] head of
it are you do you want to be reelected
because you certainly aren't operating
like you do and then that makes you go
hmm
why do they not give a [ __ ] well they
operate like that like
money they want to make all the money
and they will and they know you have a
gun to your head because if you don't
vote for them it's [ __ ] gilead right
and the worse it gets the easier it is
to just pit people right against each
other or write again it's like
i mean i think this all the goddamn time
like it is people have so much trouble
understanding a trump supporter and i
agree it is a baffling position
however when i think about who do i have
more in common with
someone who feels like the country has
left them feels like they're not secure
financially are worried about their own
situation i relate to that a lot more
than being someone who has 120 million
[ __ ] dollars in the bank yeah
so
i mean those are people who like you
know go to grocery stores know how
things operate
and
i just think they've done a magnificent
job of boiling us to enemy status with
each other when in reality you know the
enemy and they're the ones who have all
the [ __ ] money yeah they have all the
money and they're just gonna take it all
yeah and burn everything and let
everything burn it's how it appears and
they just have no [ __ ] like their
plan is to just they're like january 6th
they're going to be like boy that was
really just
that was a match and now everything's on
fire like it's just i just don't get it
like you can i mean they've militarized
the police force they've over militized
to militarize the military
that
everyone's we get it they got [ __ ]
tanks but at some point people are gonna
want water yeah and they're gonna
[ __ ] go crazy
yeah it'll be interesting
so we'll be at uh denver september 16th
paramount theater checking out the
dollop
guys i hate to interrupt this but i do
have a picture of uh dried fish bouquet
oh my god let's go baby go
oh
my god
what it's like uh
it's like a
ceviche bouquet what is happening
shrimps sardines that is crazy there's
nuts in there
no i think there's nuts in the head of
the person who bought it too salami
that's right yeah see it's very much
like a uh oh my gosh charcuterie what a
crazy world we live in yep yep
all right everybody by the way i've been
signing cars lately so uh we're back
we're back
bye-bye
you